spider
the book is called an american genocide
the united states in the california
indian catastrophe 1846 to 1873
the author
ucla professor of history benjamin
madley professor madley in your book you
write that between 1846 and 1870
california's native american population
plunged from perhaps a hundred and fifty
thousand to thirty thousand how did that
occur
so there are many things that we
understand already about this story we
know that disease
exposure
starvation
those were all major factors not only in
this population decline but in the
suppression of demographic rebound what
we didn't know in so much detail and
with so much clarity before this book
was all of the other factors and how
they played in
systematic unfree labor regimes
kidnapping
hundreds of homicides and over 370
separate massacres carried out by
vigilantes
volunteer state militiamen and elements
of the united states army all of which
come together to provide a very
convincing damning if you will argument
that what took place in california
between 1846 and 1873
was in fact a case of genocide according
to the 1948 u.n genocide convention why
1846
1846 is the year that the united states
invaded california and took california
from mexico as part of the
mexican-american war and so the story
begins there but it is also the year in
which the very first major massacre of
california indian people in this case
yana or wintu people in 1846 took place
at the hands of elements of the united
states army under john c fremont a
massacre of by all accounts peaceable
california indian people who were
gathered on the banks of the sacramento
river but whom fremont and his men
attacked preemptively killing hundreds
of individuals
what was their reasoning for this
preemptive attack they had been told by
some colonists in the northern
sacramento river valley that this group
of california indian people might pose a
threat and so they attempted through
what i call in the book pedagogic
killing to
teach a lesson to other california
indians never to resist white people and
so kit carson and john c fremont and
their band of troopers killed as many as
800 california indian people on a single
morning thus in some ways setting the
stage for what would become an american
genocide now professor madley 1846 is
only three years before the 1849 gold
rush is does gold play a role gold plays
a major role in this book in fact if we
can look at the cover of the book the
editors insisted that there be gold leaf
on it in order to not so subtly hint at
the crucial role that gold played so
before the gold rush began there were
only 13 or 14 000 non-indian people
living here in california
but between 1846 and 1870 that
population surged to hundreds and
hundreds of thousands almost 400 000
people and so that massive demographic
switch suddenly made it possible for
newcomers to entirely change their
relationship to california indians where
before the gold rush california indian
people were central to the mexican
economy serving as ranch hands as farm
workers making wine lassoing cattle
once this surge of white people came
from europe and from the eastern united
states they were no longer so crucial to
the economy and many of the newcomers
saw them as competitors
in their search for the rapid
acquisition of what wealth that shiny
gold stuff and so the massacres
accelerated dramatically during the gold
rush period particularly against
california indian communities who are
engaged in gold mining from your book
during 1849 more than 65 000 immigrants
with an e often heavily armed
experienced with paramilitary
organizations and full of fear and
hatred towards indians arrived in
california yes so they often came
already organized with officers they had
sometimes corporations
but they also had military organizations
and the literature that they were
reading the print media was telling them
that it was very dangerous to cross the
vast interior of the united states that
they were at great danger from american
indian people so one group even hauled a
cannon all the way across the united
states from west virginia to california
and they didn't find any reason to use
it and they ended up being able to sell
it for only a single dollar in
sacramento because nobody really saw
california indians as a substantial
threat many california indians as i said
before were part of the economy they
were working in the mining industries
but because everybody came so heavily
armed it made it easy for them to kill
california indians the way this worked
was that these massacres were done at
distance so long-range weapons like
rifles were used that were at a much
longer range than california indian bows
and arrows had that allowed the
attackers to kill indian people without
putting themselves in harm's way why did
you focus on california
i'm from california i grew up in indian
country in far northern california my
father was a school psychologist so i
knew a lot of kuruk and shasta people
growing up and then we moved here to los
angeles
and suddenly i was wearing an indian on
my letterman's jacket but i was
wondering where are all of the indian
people it wasn't apparent to me at that
point that we are in right now on tongva
gabrielino land the most populous indian
city in the western united states i
didn't know that so i began to wonder
where everybody went and i began to
study this history and the further i
went into it
the more terrified i became by what i
was seeing that it was the state of
california our very first democratically
elected governor in california under u.s
rule declared and i quote that a war of
extermination will be waged until the
indian race becomes extinct and at first
i thought he was some kind of rogue
madman and then i see
right away
the state legislature puts the power of
the purse behind his words raises money
originally to the tune of half a million
dollars and later they raised over 1.9
million dollars to send out 24 state
militia campaigns against california
indians which kill large numbers of
people but which inspire an even larger
number of vigilante killings meanwhile
as i got further into the story i
realized that the us army was donating
all of the weapons and ammunition to the
militias
that the federal government later
reimburses the state of california over
nine hundred thousand dollars to pay for
militias and then that the united states
army is also involved and they actually
killed more people than the california
militiamen killed and in total the
numbers are quite staggering we know
that there's this great population
decline but this book actually documents
in almost 200 pages of appendices all of
the killings and what we've learned is
that an absolute minimum these
vigilantes militiamen and united states
army soldiers killed at an absolute
minimum
9400 california indian people perhaps as
many as 16 000 and probably
thousands of others
whose deaths were not recorded in the
ledgers and letters and journals and
newspapers and official reports of the
day that i combed over for years in
order to bring all of this material
together now it might seem macabre or
like some kind of antiquarian fetish but
what i wanted to do here
was present in some way a kind of
memorial to all the fallen california
indian people who are victims of this
state-sponsored mass murder
there was a day when i was doing my
research i was a graduate student at
yale i bumped literally into this
marble plinth there's a rotund at yale
with all the names of yale men and women
who have fallen in all of the wars that
have happened since eo was founded in
1701 and it was an aha moment i thought
we need something like this for
california indian people we need to
remember now we may not get a memorial
designed by someone like maya lin
but we do have these appendices
and
if you think about your own experience
of loss the rupture and pain when you've
lost a loved one in your life
and you look at these numbers you think
about the magnitude of what this means
for california indian communities it's
not just the political leaders were lost
it's the mothers the fathers the aunties
the uncles the grandparents the people
who knew how to make a bow perfectly
the people who knew how to
weave a beautiful basket with the
traditional designs of that community
and yet after all of this
this story of almost unimaginable horror
and the state's startling involvement
in navigating and creating these
programs
you have this dark cloud of genocide in
california's history but at the same
time you have this unbelievable story of
resilience and survival so today
there are 150 000 california indian
people 109 federally recognized tribes
up and down the state another 78
california communities who are not
recognized by the federal government so
all of these people
are the descendants of folks who somehow
figured out how to survive against all
but impossible odds how to resist and
live and save themselves and their
children in a world that wanted to
destroy them
with federal soldiers
looking for them militiamen searching
for them bounty hunters who were paid by
the human scalp or by the human head
they somehow evaded all of these forces
and survived so while it's a very dark
story in many ways it's also a story of
the triumph of the human will the
triumph of our human instinct for
survival against these odds that just
seem impossible
you use the term indians and not native
americans
yes well
in the academic world we often talk
about native americans or american
indians
but i grew up in what's called indian
country and most indian people that i
know on rancherias and reservations as
well as in urban areas refer to
themselves as simply indian now we know
that this is based on columbus's great
mistake he thought that he had reached
the east indies when in fact he'd only
reach the caribbean basin
but
this term now has a kind of political
and cultural resonance that is very
important so the single biggest
periodical that circulates around indian
country is called indian country today
that is if you will the national journal
or the national periodical of american
indian people throughout this country
but it is important to acknowledge that
it is a mistake but when we think of
indian country i'm glad you raised this
it's important to remember that we're an
indian country right now we're in tongva
gabriellino land to be specific but
anywhere you go in california you'll be
in someone's ancient ancestral homeland
lands that indian people have inhabited
for thousands of years or as many
believe since time immemorial and that's
true wherever you go in the united
states in fact wherever you go in this
hemisphere from the straits of magellan
to the shores of the arctic ocean you're
in indian country and one of the things
that happened because of this great loss
of life was the erasure
of indian people in the public
consciousness
not only have all the indian names for
the land forms and the rivers and the
lakes and inlets been erased but they've
been written over often with the very
names of the people who did the killing
so we have
carson peak
and numerous places named after john c
fremont two men who we alluded to
earlier
who were direct genocide perpetrators we
also have many schools and institutions
named after
leaders in high political places who
played roles in this genocidal process
so for example
hastings law school in san francisco
this state's oldest law school is named
after the first supreme court chief
justice a man who ruled in a case that
released eight men who others had
arrested for mass murder in the napa and
sonoma valleys also a man who personally
bankrolled the death squad that later
became the eel river rangers
one of these california state militia
units that was responsible for killing
hundreds of indian people over 280 by
their own official report perhaps 400 or
more according to journalists and
eyewitness accounts
so
the very history of this genocide is
woven into our state's place names
so the way we see the cartography of
california represents this not in terms
of letting people know that here a
massacre happened here a great
enslavement of california indian people
happened here on this reservation
hundreds of people starved to death but
rather in the celebration of the very
people who planned paid for and carried
out the killing and this is one of the
things i hope that this book might help
change and i should say that on
wednesday i had the opportunity to speak
with the governor of the state of
california and to present this book
in the capitol to him and to his cabinet
and to an assembly of california indian
leaders
and he
is going to acknowledge
that this was what he calls an actual
genocide so it's a rare moment
for an historian to actually have some
impact on public discourse and what i
hope can ultimately come out of this is
a wider dialogue about how we teach our
youth i hope that
this history can ultimately get part of
the state educational standards for what
young people in california learn you
know right now it's relegated california
indian history to the fourth grade and
most of us coming up have made the sugar
cube missions maybe we did them out of
tongue depressors but that's the only
time where we talk about california
history today
and my hope as an historian as an
activist historian is to put california
indians not only into the educational
standards but into our public discourse
and
perhaps we can have monuments that
commemorate these massacres that
commemorate the victims
and that tell the truth about what
happened and once we have a more
comprehensive understanding of this mass
violence the systematic state-sponsored
mass violence that took place in
california then we can begin a healing
process that might involve not only
memorials but state mandated days of
remembrance and a real discussion about
what the state of california and what
the government of the united states owes
to california indian people in light of
this horrific criminal past
what's an activist historian
well i see myself as an activist
historian in that i'm constantly
thinking about how the documents that
i'm uncovering and the way that i tell
the narrative echoes into our lived
experience and the ways in which
uncovering hidden pasts can change
public policy public discourse and the
way that we understand the past in order
to shape our future
you spoke of the first governor of
california
your book begins in 1846 california came
into the union in 1850
back then that was a pretty quick time
frame wasn't it or not it's it's an
extraordinary thing and i'm not a
subscriber to the idea of california
exceptionalism as you well know the book
pushes against that pretty hard
but it is a very rapid turnaround why
it's because of that extraordinary
wealth provided by the gold rush and the
extraordinary migration so the migration
to california is in fact the single
largest mass migration of the united
states 19th century
so by 1850 there's already a very
substantial number of people there but
it's also because the generals in charge
were not activists and they in fact
encouraged
this democratic process to happen very
quickly so california's state
constitutional convention happens in the
fall of 1849 almost a year before
statehood so they seize the day here in
california to move very rapidly and one
of the really interesting things about
that constitutional convention is that
they came
one vote away from enfranchising
california indians so we see again and
again in this story how the history of
california could have gone in a very
very different direction but for
a very few people
turning the tide in the direction of
what ultimately became
disenfranchisement and genocide your
book was recently recognized by the la
times as well what was the uh
recognition so this book just won the
los angeles times 2017 book award for
history which is
a very exciting accolade
for a book that uncovers a dark and very
uncomfortable paths to receive why do
you why do you end it in 1873 i ended it
in 1873 because that's when the last
major organized military campaigns
against california indians concluded the
book ends with the
1872-1873 modoc war in which california
indians modoc people hold off the
combined forces of the united states
army the california state militia and
the oregon state militia for months just
a handful of them but when they finally
surrender
the process is still not over the united
states army hangs and decapitates the
four surrendered leaders before shipping
their severed heads to the u.s army war
college in washington dc to the medical
museum there
so the process comes to a conclusion in
terms of that being the last major
campaign against california indians but
it doesn't mean that the genocide
absolutely stops there benjamin madley
is an associate professor of history at
ucla and the author of this book
an american genocide the u.s and the
california indian catastrophe 1846-1873
thanks for joining us on book tv thank
you very much